today on our show we are coming home
with all right watch me and Mark shoot
our webs all over the amazing spider-man
trailer amazing Oh home spider-man
homecoming Fox yes I was in a different
game no I ran homecoming in which we
will be coming as well right now on fat
man welcome to Batman Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark Barnard as you can tell
we've got the magic black box down
mother bugs surprise we've got ourselves
a trailer to watch folks I wish I could
say we were watching this for the first
time but I'll be honest with you I've
seen this trailer 50 times Ernie
yes 412 go Webb yes this spider-man
homecoming trailer the director is John
wasa those man I believe it is kid made
cop car mmm you'd give him kids movies
because rock this kid made a [ __ ]
movie looks like a goddamn comic book I
once read and I know I didn't read this
story it doesn't exist a myth in the
pages or any of this [ __ ] story
brand-new story man
breathlessly told breathtakingly told as
well in this trailer now mmm is there
any way on earth after trailer this
[ __ ] delicious but this movie
disappoints no way right now
and if this movie opens to like 200
million dollars it just doesn't I'll be
honest this is the first spider-man
movie like I was like hey I'll see those
about the other ones but this is the
first one that I'm like I need to see
this he's amazing there but you know
spider-man in high school and having to
be a kid instead of like I like total
Maguire but got sporty nice enough
harder looks like Peter Parker like a
kid in high school gets powers only way
it would have been possibly better is if
they did the other kid miles but you
know all the time we do get it down the
Glover in this one anyway yeah so and
who knows maybe Spiderman graduation we
get to Miles Morales like so good when
the [ __ ] I was done homecoming
graduation because they want to do one a
year so i guess is he meant to be a
freshman oh I don't think so I don't get
that behind off when he's a sophomore
that means they can get three more while
they're in high school I don't know
concentration on Mary Jane know though
you do get a lot kissy Kissy
towards the end well that one shot ways
I got hurt everyone you love and stuff
like that's not Mary Jane that's another
that's another girl is it I think so if
I remember correctly because she I think
from the first trailer the girl who was
sitting at the table and said some [ __ ]
I'm Annette that's Mary Jane right so I
think we're meant to be misdirected mmm
I think because it looks like their
approach for Mary Jane as opposed to
being like you hit the jackpot tiger and
looking like a like like butcher [ __ ]
who was in spider-man movies they hung
upside a guy hung upside guess what's it
mean could bang
Kristin duck first or sometimes instead
of looking like person dance like she
looks edgy like yeah punk punk chick but
do you then get they like that the
Rachael Leigh Cook she's all that moment
where like she takes off her glasses and
pulls the pin out of her hair's like oh
[ __ ] you're beautiful all time I just
didn't see it
oh you know maybe in another move these
marble cats mmm they're telling good
stories yeah they're not going not going
big and broad and stupid like now
they're gone nice teeth oh let's turn it
on its head I don't know if they would
do that I mean at the temptations there
I mean if you're gonna because that's
also a beautiful girl who's just this
planners in daya is playing Mary Jane
and how do you [ __ ] turd uh polish it
looks converse of that like how you
can't polish a turd but how do you how
do you dress down somebody that's
looking at that's cute Wow well that's
the idea maybe that's on that story the
idea is like you know hey it doesn't
have to be the girl that looks like the
cover girl maybe it should be the more
interesting or something like that and
Peter Parker is more interesting guy
they're actually picturing something of
a nerd stuff like we like even nerd like
that we like them of the outside I'll be
honest with you we're reviewing this
trailer probably even watched it but
that's because we've seen a lot my
favorite part of the trailer is I grew
up the fat kid leaves Jenna I don't know
vanilla and one of the things you always
wonder as a fat kid is like jeez what
would i look like if spider-man see this
append there's a moment in this trailer
where they let is that supposed to be
Ned leads
mmm I think that to a victor character
supposed to be dead leads old spider-man
character from a dick Cody Wow
but they let him have the student goes
can I try on the suit and the nature of
the suit is that it's puffy and it
suctions up to you so anybody could
where I saw that mom in the trailer I
roll the tears like finally finally a
fat boys in the suit the dream deferred
alright so without further ado we're
gonna dive in and you're gonna watch us
watch this
coming on Homecoming here we go and that
we're on the first frame of the trailer
ready kids and press play
oh this instantly that the addition of
the suction suit brilliant right away
fun look at the good times he's having
he's won with his neighborhood Tony
Stark as if we weren't pretty soulful
going to make Queens do swinging through
the trees and [ __ ] like that as if we
weren't pre-sold they put Tony Stark in
the spool
I think that's meant to be Ned would
either get a spider-man oh my god the
ending shot my show key so minimum you
swingers that's adorable
man all them that yeah that's adorable
stole a shield that makes me cry
powerful like Stark damn camera he's got
the furry collar shillings everybody
loves me surely
these cats I think are meant to be
damage control from the comics while
they clean up this is here Adrian Toomes
right and this is [ __ ] astounding and
I can't believe they're showing it that
this is laughs it is awesome whoop that
bit is so doesn't but they're showing us
this and letting us know that like this
inning in the third act
nope is just something I get to suit
take it away but him go no no no no and
then hold that is so heroic that's the
kind of sounding and look at that just
like a [ __ ] good comic book man here
comes a here at about the might be like
you
how'd you do I'm gonna get back well I'm
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing about this suit that you
shouldn't have
there you go there's the whole team in
the movie right power comes great
responsibility you're nothing without a
suit you should never Aunt May
look at this [ __ ] like from Batman to
Birdman to bad man Shyamalan dude
that means the tinkers in this as well
haha look at spider-man fighting in what
looks like the Scarlet Spider suit hmm
we're gonna pick them up dude that's
[ __ ] messianic that's so beautiful
that little bit never saw that before
love the disco webs under his arms or
you could call the Avengers but do they
need the Bulger badass never thought it
possible
come on just don't do anything stupid
how everybody literally trying to
[ __ ] to stop the plane from pensive
buildings in New York [ __ ] a [ __ ]
a man
what's better than that nothing if
somebody was like Amen you want to see
that movie and then die I'd be like I
guess that's gonna be better than that
[ __ ] nothing Jesus that looks good
now do you think I can't think I'm
sucking stupid lights light devil's
advocate do you think Renard don't don't
not to all this away all I'm gonna say
is do you think there might be a hair
too much Tony Stark in that no [ __ ] no I
say more Tony Stark where's Thor I said
put them all in no not at all I look I
think they're just hedging their bets
man and make zonies like look it's
marble real marble I mean like we all
know till he starts in the movie it's
not as if it was a big reveal they're
hiding from it but if I kind of want
them to trust spider-man to be enough to
get me there but I mean I'm [ __ ] one
too much do yeah I learned a subtle I'm
an indie filmmaker so basically I'm a
different theory which is like have good
enough and then you move on you think
everything no getting drunk that's good
enough that trailer is beyond good
enough I don't know I killed that little
you're like well did you notice as much
[ __ ] that I'm like why didn't they show
us the rest of the movie I want to see
it now I mean I'm not one of those
people it's like oh they spoil too much
in the Carroll I'm like God did you ever
see the trailers in the 70s they
literally take home the last shot of the
movie right before the planets rule but
here all the jobs are very low I showed
you smile you saw me but everything
blown up you're like well I guess I'm
not gonna see that anymore so yeah you
could show me everything dude [ __ ]
Michael key from mr. mom [ __ ] from
Chuck and Bill's [ __ ] cemetery Murray
is in next show yet with Henry Winkler
Ron Howard from that from mr. mom gungho
Beetlejuice - Batman - later on Birdman
and now another bird man who is a bad
oh so many man's and a lot of man man
he's all man uh that [ __ ] vulture
outfit looks phenomenal and the idea
from what I've read online is they all
it's the terrible tinker and shocker and
vulture and before they take on their
personas or whatever they work for
damage control which is which is an
awesome very Qasim but very close to you
know there's that show on NBC carmela
list but damage control is a combo that
I collected back in the day so more than
one first of the idea of a company that
cleans up after all these [ __ ] super
battles so for a while it seems like
tombs is people clean up after like the
invasion of the sense of means re
invasion would not and then Tony Stark
after the events of civil war or
something like that is like we've got to
keep a clamp down on this technology
it's getting into the wrong hands
and so these cleanup companies don't get
to do the work anymore and that's when
they're like let's take this [ __ ] we
found and turn them into weapons wow
that's a cool [ __ ] story I'm so on
board for this I'm in the bag so in the
bag I mean I have caught in the web I am
too in the bag I'm just you know you
know how I do you know me I just want to
I want to see something so beautiful so
perfect that you are like I have nothing
except crazy
Amazo it's going to be a mugga Buffy
trailer a man's reach should exceed his
grasp and what's our heaven for that's
true oh my god poetic we go out
poetically was more poetic than that
trailer the way mark has ended our dopey
little Internet go web there it is we
have reacted to spider-man homecoming
and boy was that reaction enthusiastic
come back and watch us react to Justice
League how it's just started battle
that's alright any event that's it for
this week's Batman I'm Batman
then I'm Kevin stone I'm open or come
back next episode same fat time same fat
channel SModcast comport youtube.com
slash company from their psyche
[Music]
you
[Music]